[Music]
hey what up this your boy david lucas
man welcome to my show flatliner come
get these [ __ ] jokes man i'm
giving it to everybody who want that
fire
pull up that's all you got to do pull up
noah bring your whole ass there you go
hey
look at it we got a [ __ ] tractor
mechanic
on the phone what's up boy what up
yeah well you look like you got to let
the pigs out before you go to school in
the morning
[Laughter]
what's up dog
yeah boy you you the hands you're the
most handsome lesbian i've ever seen in
my life bro you
you [ __ ] smooth face [ __ ]
look at you dog hell yeah you [ __ ]
all universe chris deleo look at you
dude you need to take some testosterone
bro god damn you got no facial hair
you the youngest 33 year old i ever seen
in my life what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you bro you
you got too much estrogen in your system
dog i know your bones is probably
brittle
where you probably in your life with a
with a slipping fall
[ __ ] brutal [ __ ] brittle bone
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
hey man go home and start doing some
push-ups right now bro
[Laughter]
look at pedro
you look like you got a garage band
called the
llamas look at pedro
look at it bro you you stole your daddy
lawrence truck to take the all the uh
band gear to a concert
okay
where the [ __ ] you at with all them
clothes though you cool [ __ ]
it's cold bro i don't got here
where you at
i'm in the bag
that boy called it live from my ice cap
yo
yeah hey
your titties so big they use it as a
life preserver when you're grounded
you look like a bully out of tijuana
high school
[Laughter]
you look like a gender-neutral drug mule
hit me with another bro who's that hit
me with another one
ah what's another
and
uh one time i noticed there was a
frito's honey chip shortage in the bay
and then i saw your name on the marquee
at the punchline
all right bro i caught your ass uh
snorting salsa verde [ __ ]
as uh
boy did a lot of salsa verde on new
year's get your stupid ass out of here
boy like a mexican steven cigar looking
ass
[Laughter]
look at him boy it must be a full moon
tonight like you about to turn into a
werewolf [ __ ]
david get this [ __ ]
get this [ __ ] david well get the [ __ ]
out of here you look like you look like
i can't plug it
it's my
[ __ ] your birthday
birthday yeah give me give me a real
good one
seth rogen call he said he want his face
back [ __ ]
put your black friend back on
yeah
i went down with joe ass well you look
like you sell uh you look like you sell
dying back to white people for a hundred
dollars get your stupid ass out of here
when your mixtape drop [ __ ] your ass
can flip the [ __ ] out of a burger [ __ ]
yeah yeah boy you look like you about to
shoot up at school
[Laughter]
you you look like you should be at
necktie house getting the garbage plate
yeah shut those stupid ass up you like
you beat up your mama over your
skateboard
nah no skateboard no more yeah
yeah you uh you one of them guys on the
high school football team who fell in
the pothole every during every warm-up
you look like you started a strike in
your neighborhood with the rest of the
white kids because you couldn't listen
to rap music
[Laughter]
from detroit baby
yeah boy yo i look like you you look
like you jack off the eight mile video
[ __ ] shut your stupid ass up be rabbit
look at that
now you uh
you you looking like you uh
where are you getting your haircut from
uh yeah well goofy as [ __ ] but you look
like you got suspended from school you
like you got suspended from your private
school for wearing jeans
[Laughter]
no but no private school here
will smith and fresh prince is your
spirit animal
[Laughter]
man
yeah well that looked like you about to
do news talk radio [ __ ] get your stupid
ass up out of here
rogan looking ass
what's up dog oh [ __ ] what's up bro look
at this
time you made that sweatshirt my
feelings hurt my feelings bro i've been
believing this let's go you know how to
make jordans by hand
[Laughter]
again well you made it you made all that
[ __ ] thick boy like about that
counterfeit thick boy
i just i just made these like literally
right before you called yeah i could
tell i see them still steaming we got to
ship them to justin
[Laughter]
the stitching's off so you can tell
yeah
you ever seen rush hour
that's my favorite movie bro you know
how you buy the people
you look like you about to pay 150
million to get your daughter back
[Laughter]
i bet when you nut it smell like ramen
[Laughter]
i mean it shoots out like ramen
yeah well
you got a back tattoo to say made in
china
boy you got a fat [ __ ] clothes oh yo
yo ass i hear my outfit oh what the [ __ ]
wrong with you
that [ __ ] boy yo yo
you're calling participate in the dunk
contest [ __ ] that [ __ ] it like a
[ __ ]
why you got a big ass clothes though
i like oversight [ __ ] you know damn bro
i feel it bro yo as you stop hanging
around white people look yo that's crazy
everybody get baptized ain't a big
t-shirt where they're about to go to
grandma's house
hey what's up man thank y'all for tuning
in thank you for everybody who
participated man we gonna do this every
week so make sure you tap in if you want
to be roasted and i'm always gonna be
here flatline with your boy david lucas
man peace
you